and I want to remind all of you it's
really important to have these like
connecting lines in between it's just
like when you write um when you're
writing a paragraph in an essay about a
text you say what text you're talking
about right and then you even underline
that sometimes to make it really obvious
what am I talking about
well what you're talking to do is this
equation double while you're talking
about here is these equations subtract
it and whatever happens to be okay now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to do
just like I did here to the left-hand
side all together to do the right hand
side all together
here is the left hand side of equation
one and I'm going to subtract the left
hand side of equation to a lexer hey
happy with that it's just a substitution
it's just a swamp there that's fine what
about the right-hand side it's five
there and it's 14 there okay with me
so this is why the reasons why you know
labeling your equations carefully is so
important okay
I've written it out and now I can start
to work with that this first pair of
brackets is really quite redundant but
it did make it neater for me to separate
out which bits which here I have to be
careful when I expand because of this
minus sign what's gonna happen yeah so
this minus 2x is just minus 2x and this
is going to be the opposite of an
opposite is back to the original thing
so that's going to be plus forward yeah
on the right hand side I've just got
some numbers
are you okay now we're almost at the
point where we have actually eliminated
things as we intended what you've got is
this 2x and this would minus 2x
colliding with each other okay so
they're gone and all the left with is
these new guys when you click like terms
there are seven oh yeah last little
piece I guess I need to get the Y by
itself so I will divide by seven which
leaves you with that now that looks a
bit icky you know sometimes you get an
answer you like something nice and neat
and that looks worse okay well number
one this is why we don't rely on
graphically solving things all the time
because you wouldn't never guess that as
your answer right you'd never read your
table with your oh that's exactly - 9/7
right we'll find out in a second if this
actually matches up as we can substitute
back inside
what would you like me to do with this
because I'm not done yet Emma
I have I have a whole bunch of different
wishes
okay now what I want is just I got the Y
so I just want the X do you agree with
that just want the X now it looks to me
like the easiest spot where I just have
an X right there do you agree with that
you see how it's by itself I don't
identify by anything so I'm going to
substitute this into equation 2 let me
explain what's going on so you can see
the first line I've written here that's
just a substitution everyone should have
the same right here you care with that
yeah okay so that's just me replacing Y
when I went down to here you can see
I've done two things one to the left one
to the right on the left hand side I've
said two times nine and it's actually
minus 2 and minus 9 so that becomes an
18 and it's a positive yes
that's seventh left alone now that's
dealt with my left-hand side now I know
I'm eventually gonna have to go to the
right-hand side think of this a little
bit like when you're driving you like oh
I'm gonna turn onto this road but the
next turn I'm gonna have it make will be
a right turn so might as well get in the
right lane well when I write this number
I could have just written it as a 7
right but I know it's gonna have to do a
dance for this guy and you see what the
denominator is
right it's a seven Oh might as well just
change that into a denominator 7 if this
were like a six or something like that
well I changes into a denominator six
just so these guys can talk with each
other does that make sense
okay 49 over seven is just another way
of writing 7 ok can you see what I did
there I just subtracted did I do it
correctly yeah ok now even though I
agree like when I look at this pair of
numbers
really I'm loving super convinced we
know there's an easy way to test if
these solutions right I can put it back
in now would you like to give me
suggestions which one do you think I
should click them into now to be fair if
we if I wanted to do this perfectly I
should put it into both 1 & 2 because
that's what I started with remember but
think about this I've kind of already
done one of them have a 9
haven't I already done too I just did
that and if what I've done here is
correct
then I don't need to do it all over
again really all that's left is to check
one ok so let's have a good go
let's test whoa this is web why is this
wet that's just like what are you okay
test there's water you can say all right
so on the left-hand side I've got 2x
plus 3y so 2x plus 3y and now I'm going
to take what I think X is and what I
think Y is and let's see what happens to
X that's two this has my substitution
look two times 31 3 and negative nine
there show you - 27 shouldnít yep 62
takeaway 27 I'm pretty sure that's 35
now so even though it weird
well the maths confirms it and if you
want jory like double triple quadra
before you can pop back into equation 2
but we've already done that so I'm
satisfied ok ok now well done we got to
the end let's just rewind all the way
back to this slide like this is the
first thing I wrote down to actually
start solving the question and I told
you back then I was like well it's not
clear why I'm doing this now do you see
why I did this for example why do you
think I went for two rather than three
or four or five to get it today okay
because I was like look I've got one X
me up I want these two to be the same
okay yeah so that's the first thing
now that's the end of this number why do
you think I went after equation two and
I looked at equation one I said forget
it I'm not mucking in equation
okay so the first thing is like if I
wanted these two to be talking the same
language right then I have to divide
this by two which is gonna make that
fraction make that a fraction no thanks
right or if I wanted to do the Y you can
have to multiply both of these by
numbers like you'd multiply this one to
this one point three of course I'd
rather avoid that if I can't sometimes
you have to I'll deal with those maybe a
bit later on but this is the basic
mechanics of it make a smart choice
it's a minimize the amount of what you
have to do okay